do you think that men owe a woman
loyalty if she was there from the
beginning absolutely they absolutely owe
that woman I'm sorry sexual loyalty
that's what I meant sexual sexual
exclusivity yeah it's different ma'am
sorry I mean
sexual exclusivity and loyalty are
completely disconnected for males nobody
wants to talk about this but it's the
unfortunate reality is true I'm telling
you you can get a man he can go on a
holiday and [__] some stripper to come
home and you can lie detect or test him
do you love your wife would you die for
your wife would you take a bullet for
your wife he'll pass the lie detector
test he loves her with all his heart he
do anything for her it's just it's just
it's okay